stiamo investendo miliardi sul futuro
ma sul futuro di chi
basta aprire un giornale la tv o
qualsiasi social network per vedere le
innovazioni che ogni giorno arrivano
digitali tecnologiche solo per citarne
alcune ogni anno spendiamo miliardi e
miliardi per creare nuovi prodotti e
metterli sul mercato ma una domanda mi
viene spontanea
quanto stiamo investendo su coloro che
saranno il nostro futuro
quanto sui bambini e sulle nuove
competenze
la risposta è poco
e questo è un campanello d'allarme
perché oggi stiamo costruendo le basi
per il nostro futuro
non pensiamo che il futuro sia a 300
anni è molto più vicino di quanto noi
crediamo
Io ne sono l'esempio
Quando ho iniziato l'università 11 anni
fa la mia attuale professione di user
Experience designer stava muovendo in
Italia in quegli anni i primi passi per
darvi un'idea generale del contesto i
social network stavano arrivando in
quegli anni in Italia i più noti ancora
neanche esistevano Non avevo internet
sullo smartphone e delle chat di gruppo
ancora non c'era neanche un'idea che
forse questo era un bene
per darvi un'altra pillola alle
elementari Non avevo il computer
portatile ma una macchina da scrivere
rossa con il nastro che ogni 3x2 si
inceppava
l'arrivo del computer ha profondamente
cambiato sia la mia vita che la mia vita
da studentessa dislessica
ora mi capita spesso di andare nelle
scuole raccontare quella che era la mia
vita da bambina dislessica negli anni 90
come studiavo come interagivo i bambini
mi guardano sorridano e spesso mi fanno
più grande di quella che io sia
veramente mi racconti un aneddoto
divertente qualche anno fa mi trovavo in
una classe e stavo raccontando quella
che era la mia esperienza ad un certo
punto i bambini erano in fila per
tornare alla loro classe un bambino
corre verso di me mi dà con una
disinvoltura una pacca sulla spalla e mi
esclama sai il prossimo anno diventa
dislessico pure io
mi fermo tra me e penso Magari si
potesse scegliere se Essere o non essere
dislessici io a quell'età del bambino
non avrei mai immaginato come si sarebbe
trasformata la mia vita e quella di
tutti noi
ancora oggi tendiamo spesso a chiedere
cosa vorrei fare da grande o dove ti
vedi Tra 10 anni ma rispondere a questa
domanda Oggi non è assolutamente facile
perché siamo in un contesto in continua
evoluzione
secondo il the world economics forum
Infatti il 65% dei bambini che oggi si
trova nella scuola primaria svolgerà un
lavoro che ancora non esiste o che sta
muovendo oggi i primi passi
Dobbiamo iniziare a costruire quelle che
sono le nuove competenze perché siamo
tutti su un aereo che non sappiamo dove
atterrerà ma dobbiamo iniziare a
familiare con il volo e far capire ai
bambini le potenzialità del digitale e
non fartelo vedere solo come uno
strumento di gioco o di divago ma
comunque qualcosa di bello per iniziare
a costruire il futuro
nelle aziende come nelle scuole il si è
sempre fatto così unito alla paura di
sbagliare e alla paura di uscire dalla
comfort zone ci stanno facendo perdere
competitività verso quello che è il
futuro Ora siamo in un periodo florido
per l'apprendimento di tutti noi non ce
lo dimentichiamo
pensi che questo a te che non hai
bambini o che li hai Ormai grandi non ti
coinvolga
Ti sbagli questo coinvolge tutti noi
perché i bambini di oggi sono i medici
gli ingegneri di domani che magari ti
opereranno con un robot ci avevi mai
pensato
non esiste una sola strada ma ne
esistono tante io nel mio piccolo sto
portando avanti un progetto che ha
l'obiettivo di trasmettere i bambini le
basi e le metodologie della professione
del lusser Experience designer colui che
progetta interazioni uomo macchina molti
di voi sicuramente non avranno mai
sentito parlare di questa professione
avete oggi usato uno smartphone Ho
navigato online Sì ottimo avete trovato
problemi avete ricercato con facilità o
siete dovuti andare a cercare in un
manuale come farlo no con facilità
ottimo avete toccato con mano quello che
lavoro dell'usura Experience designer
ora vi chiedo voi avete mai pensato di
progettare un'applicazione per
smartphone da 0 no con un gruppo di
bambini di 10-13 anni lo abbiamo fatto
lo abbiamo progettato un'app Per
sensibilizzare i compagni di classe a
portare la borraccia anziché ogni giorno
acquistare una nuova bottiglietta in
plastica il prossimo mese faremo
qualcosa di ancora più grande un
laboratorio dove andremo a progettare
un'app che ha l'obiettivo di
sensibilizzare il mondo degli adulti a
svolgere la raccolta differenziata in
modo corretto la progetteranno i bambini
la progetteranno e toccheranno con mano
tutte quelle che saranno le fasi del
lussore Experience designer dalla
ideazione creazione
prototipo cioè un fac simile di come
verrà poi effettivamente l'applicazione
fino al test
Indovinate su chi andremo a testare se
funziona questa applicazione sui loro
genitori che avranno modo di apprendere
un qualcosa di nuovo e chi lo sa Magari
l'indomani riportarlo anche in azienda
progettando applicazioni non mettiamo
solo un seme in quella che potrebbe
essere la carriera dei bambini del
futuro ma daremo a loro tante competenze
sociali che spesso la scuola non offre
come la capacità di lavorare in gruppo
di interagire o di prendere decisioni in
modo rapido
non continuiamo con il si è sempre fatto
così ma piuttosto
Impariamo ad imparare
Questa sarà la chiave per il nostro
futuro
lo dice anche un rapporto della
commissione europea
Infatti saremo tutti noi sempre di più
all'interno di un contesto di un
continuo apprendimento saremo sempre
continuano a mente ad apprendere e a
mettere sul campo nuove competenze tutti
noi
Perciò ora vi chiedo su cosa vogliamo
investire per il nostro futuro
[Applauso]